Wherever there's an ocean, there's
going to be some big empire
that wants to control it.
But there's one ocean,
up at the top of the world
that hasn't ever been controlled
by great powers
because it's
literally frozen most of the time.
But that’s changing
because up here in the Arctic,
things are heating up four times
faster than the rest of the planet.
And some big countries see a lot of money
and influence hiding under the ice.
There are deposits of fossil fuels.
Shipping routes. And minerals.
So what it's turned into
is all of these countries: Russia,
the United States, and even China,
who's not even an Arctic country,
but kind of wants to
be an Arctic country.
But just isn't.
All of them are now vying
for influence in the Arctic.
Greenland belongs
to the kingdom of Denmark.
They are a member of the military
alliance called NATO.
The U.S.
even has a military base up here.
But Greenland is also kind of tied
to China.
A lot of their economy relies
on sending fish to China.
The result of all of this is tension.
More and more every year.
I actually went to Greenland
to try
to understand
what this really important island
means for the future of
influence in the Arctic.